[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour une
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
sur tv 78 nous sommes le lundi 27
novembre tout de suite les titres de ce
set 8 journal il a été lancé ce matin à
paris le jeu virus soir revient pour un
deuxième opus initiative de
l'association hf prévention basée à
trappes
l aventure est donc cette fois ci en
réalité virtuelle et le but toujours le
même
combattre le sida en plateau nous
recevons jérôme andré directeur de hf
prévention elles sont environ 30% de
femmes entrepreneurs à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines créactive
accompagné fédère ces porteuses de
projet à l'association organise demain
ses septièmes rencontres cette hausse
qui cube à guyancourt présentation dans
cette édition avec nos invités
et puis retour sur un événement qui
fêtait son dixième anniversaire à
versailles le salon histoire de lire se
tenait ce week-end dans la cité royale
plusieurs célébrités du livre de la
télévision encore de la politique était
présente en compagnie de 20000 visiteurs
avant de développer ses titres ils ont
entamé aujourd'hui à guyancourt leur
quinzième jour de grève
trois salariés de sodexo continue la
mobilisation devant le siège du groupe
de restauration collective ses employés
du site de dreux en eure-et-loir
réclament le paiement de leurs jours non
travaillés
un mouvement qui a débuté suite à
l'annoncé de la fermeture prochaine de
la cuisine centrale de dreux un plan de
sauvegarde de l'emploi a été validé par
les syndicats sodexo affirme avoir à un
contact sérieux avec un repreneur qui
devrait sauver une vingtaine d 62 postes
actuels sur le site euréliens un combat
long et difficile en france environ cent
cinquante trois mille personnes vivent
avec le vih à vendredi c'est la journée
mondiale de lutte contre le sida
à cette occasion l'association achète
prévention a présenté ce matin sa
nouvelle application virus war 2 le
laser-game du précédent opus a laissé
place à une simulation en réalité
virtuelle
les précisions de nicolas kirillovitch
mais l'état
puis de trithérapie d'antibiotiques à
mon commandement
la guerre contre le virus du sida se
poursuit
nouvel épisode dans ce conflit pour hf
prévention l'association yvelinoise a
dévoilé sa nouvelle application virus
war 2 une expérience où le mode la
réalité virtuelle pour essayer de tuer
l'ennemi dans un jeu ludique et
interactif ça a été reproduit donc
réellement c'est à dire qu'on a vraiment
les la syphilis est vraiment la syphilis
qui représentait comme ça si on
regardait donc au microscope et vous
allez le voir quand on est dans le virus
du sida et qu'on voit le virus du sida
il se répliquent et donc c'est ça le
danger est donc il se réplique pour
devrait aussi dans l'organisme utilisé
le virtuel pour mieux pénétrer le réel
la nouvelle application est
principalement dédié aux 15 à 25 ans un
public qu'il est difficile de concernés
avec les messages de prévention habituel
si vous aimez un film où vous avez un
film parce qu'il vous provoque une
émotion et donc vous vous souvenez soit
de deux tirades de deux phrases entre
deux acteurs parce qu'ils vous ont
provoqué une émotion le game 'changer
c'est un peu le même principe on vous
provoque une émotion au travers d'un jeu
immersif et ça vous provoque une émotion
qui vous permet de retenir le message
essentiel dont pour nous d'en virer soir
préservatifs et dépistage l'association
basée à trappes a profité de ce
lancement pour faire aussi le point sur
les autres dispositifs qu'elle développe
comme l'application tubes pour trouver
un préservatif ou encore des autotests
vih qui permettent de savoir en une
minute
selon les dernières données en france
trente mille personnes ignorent qu'elles
sont séropositives
c'est donc l'association hf prévention
basée à trappes qui est à l'origine de
ce virus wars 2 bonsoir jérôme andré
êtes le directeur de cette association
hf prévention c'est une application dont
qui utilise un procédé très à la mode en
ce moment c'est la réalité virtuelle
c'est nécessaire d'utiliser voilà style
de procéder pour sensibiliser les jeunes
à ce qui est important c'est de pouvoir
diffuser très largement virus soir le 1
c'est un laser game
600 mètres carrés de zones de jeu à
déplacer ce n'est pas toujours facile
aujourd'hui on a des outils comme ce
style de casques où les gens peuvent
télécharger une application le mettre
dedans et ils vont être immergées
directement dans un sous-marin ce qui va
leur permettre de pouvoir détruire les
virus les infections sexuellement
transmissibles et aussi donc le virus du
sida alors ça a été évoqué pendant le
sujet on appelle virus soir on appelle
ça un game challenger c'est c'est tout
nouveau
ça c'est sorti il ya deux ans beaucoup
de pays sont en train donc de sortir des
gaines 'changer again ginger l'idée
c'est de pouvoir modifier les
comportements des gens et séance à 2
c'est novateur c'est à dire qu'on va
pouvoir effectivement dire eh bien
demain on va sur la contraception
proposait des gaines 'changer qui vont
faire prendre conscience qu'on peut
avoir une une contraception adaptée à
chaque moment de sa vie donc on a
effectivement cette innovation qui ouvre
ses portes
donc depuis deux ans les américains sont
les ont l'ont sorti il ya un prix nobel
dans quai qui est apparu cette année
pour quelqu'un qui avait créé un game
challenger en économie donc il existe
des tas de ganja en santé sexuelle et
plus particulièrement en santé il n'en
existe que 2-1 sur le cancer qui a été
fait par les américains et puis virent
aux soins ce qui est effectivement donc
à la fois l'épisode 1 et maintenant
l'épisode 2 ce qui va permettre
effectivement de modifier les
comportements des gens 600 en 2015 à
l'époque du virus wars 1 ce métier les
les deuxièmes finalement dans le monde a
lancé un game challenger sur le thème de
la soirée
exactement est donc assez le 3ème game
challenger donc on est toujours les
petits numéros 2 et puis on a dans le
pipe line 3 4 games 'changer sur la
santé des femmes
1 / effectivement tout ce qui va être
contraception et aussi sur la nutrition
parce qu'aujourd'hui on se rend bien
compte qu'il faut aller au devant des
gens avec des tests avec des autotests
mais aussi avec des nouvelles techniques
on voit tuk tuk aujourd'hui c'est un
formidable souvent préservatif qui est
un présage effet un lieu de dépistage
partout en france et 200 mille
utilisateurs réguliers qu'ils ont dans
leur poche
la marraine c'est marina carrère
d'encausse du journal de la santé de
france 5
et c'est vrai qu'on voit bien ça répond
à une nécessité aujourd'hui on est
dedans
digital il convient de faire de la
prévention nouvelles générations de la
prévention digital alors tu peux virus
voir tout il ya un autre 2 pardon un
autre une autre application
une autre campagne pardon qui est lancée
par l'association hf prévention on est
dans la semaine forcément de cette
journée mondiale contre le sida c'est
une campagne s'appelle clash le sida
c'est sur les réseaux sociaux c'est un
hashtag en fait clash le cdh le sida
donc effectivement le montrent avec du
health care ça va permettre de pouvoir
de clash et donc le sida sur facebook
sur twitter sur les réseaux sociaux les
gens vont pouvoir se prendre en photo
vont pouvoir mettre des petites phrases
pour clasher donc le sida le hca classe
le sida ça se fait en partenariat avec
le crips ile de france quand on est
ravis effectivement que ça se fasse avec
eux toutes les écoles vont pouvoir
participer aussi à ça et d'ailleurs
vendredi nous serons à mantes la jolie
pour proposer virus soir un virus war 2
clash le sida b you tube heures des
concerts
ça va être vraiment un moment de fête
contre le sida clasher sida c'est bien
sûr en parler c'est encore difficile il
ya un tabou aujourd'hui ça reste tabou
nous ne le voit clairement ça reste
tabou les gens ne vont pas forcément au
dépistage on est content d'avoir ces
hausses et rod ces tests rapides
d'orientation de dépistage à nouveau
camion nous c'est fournit d'ailleurs par
la région ile de france
et puis c'est vrai que là aussi c'est
autotests 1600 autotests ont été
distribués par un chef prévention c'est
colossal ça permet justement de rendre
le dépistage beaucoup plus accessible
aux gens disponibles distribués par
hachette prévention c'est aussi
disponible en pharmacie depuis deux ans
et est disponible en pharmacie depuis
deux ans et c'est un véritable succès on
a effectivement donc de bons retours sur
le fait que les gens n'ont plus peur
d'aller enfin massip legrand demander
effectivement des autotests et pouvoir
donc les acheter oui d'ailleurs ce matin
ça a été aussi l'occasion de rappeler
toute l'utilité on sait qu'en france il
ya environ trente mille personnes qui
vivent avec le vih vih sans le savoir
minimum au minimum oui nous on a plutôt
tendance à dire entre 30 et 80 mille
personnes seniors parce que quand on
regarde les courbes même on a des gens
qu'ils le savent et qui ne vont pas
forcément aux soins qui sont dans le
déni donc c'est important de rappeler
qu' il est important de se faire
dépister il est d'autant plus important
aussi d'emmener les gens aux soins pour
qu'ils puissent être traités le plus
rapidement possible aujourd'hui on sait
que quelqu'un qui est traitée rapidement
et quelqu'un qui derrière
viens potentiellement non contaminée
dernière chose sur hf prévention
l'actualité il ya une nouveaux locaux ça
c'est en juillet et l'association qui
développe aussi ses autres missions
on sait on connaît l'éducation à la
sexualité mais aussi la nutrition la
nutrition le diabète les problèmes
cardiovasculaires et c'est vrai que pour
le coup on va créer effectivement du
dépistage de l'innovation de légumes
'changer sur cette thématique là parce
que il y a un grand besoin aujourd'hui
de de déployer la prévention largement
et de manière efficace
merci jérôme andré d'avoir un directeur
de hachette prévention et pour plus
d'informations sur l'association ses
missions rendez vous sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
et je précise que virus wars 2 est
disponible gratuitement sur google play
et l'app store
un peu moins d'un mois des fêtes de fin
d'année les listes de cadeaux et des a's
achats se prépare déjà cette année
pourquoi ne pas faire un noël écolo
c'est en tout cas le pari de
l'association plaisir en transition et
qui lance le défi zéro déchet à noël ou
comment se faire plaisir et offrir sans
polluer la planète nicolas landry et les
arrêts ch
al'approche des fêtes de noël les
supermarchés et grandes enseignes
préparent leurs vitrines pour donner l
envie d'acheter
mais cet hiver l'association plaisir en
transition propose le défi zéro déchet
en réduisant d'abord sa consommation
globalement on est une vingtaine de
famille à s'être associé et
dans le même but de réduire nos déchets
donc un peu changé sa consommation pour
alléger nos poubelles qui font 400 kg
normalement à l'année en moyenne donc le
but c'est de réduire de 30% calendrier
de l'avent avec des rouleaux de papier
toilette ou encore des sapins sans
épines et recyclables les bonnes idées
fusent lors des ateliers
selon l'ademe chaque personne jette plus
d'un kilo de déchets par jour
l'objectif de l'association est donc
d'abord de sensibiliser au quotidien le
zéro déchet c'est pas une mode c'est un
mode de vie c'est tout simplement de
faire attention d'être consom'acteurs de
faire attention à ce qu'on consomme 2
de trouver des alternatives à mener de
manière ludique et intelligente ce défi
zéro déchet pour noël inclut les grands
comme les petits
avec la maman pour les mouchoirs de la
check une fois et docks à preuve les
croquer à noël zéro déchet je suis venu
ce matin un petit peu pour pour voir
comment je peux réduire les déchets pour
noël notamment ce qui m'intéresserait
c'est de faire en fait un sapin de noël
zéro des chefs valoriser les cadeaux qui
ne sont pas matérielle est une des
solutions zéro déchet la hotte du père
noël promet d'être écolo en 2017
c'est votre rendez vous chaque fin de
mois sur tv 78 le dossier de la
rédaction cette semaine
à nous vous proposons une série de
reportages sur le fait main dans les
yvelines sur ces artisans du département
ce soit rencontre avec sandrine delumeau
elle créa plaisir des écharpes en soie
découverte avec nicolas dans prix
quoi de mieux que le salon du made in
france à paris pour mettre en avant
l'artisanat des yvelines originaire de
plaisir sandrine delhumeau expose ses
créations des écharpes en soie sous la
bannière de l'association la révolution
du fait main une fabrication manuelle et
artisanale est essentielle pour li
blinoise il ya l'importance du geste
la maîtrise d'un geste
la qualité du travail aussi la précision
modélistes de formation voilà cinq ans
qu'elle produit des écharpes
une activité qu'elle a débuté par hasard
lorsqu'elle occupé son premier poste
dans une tissuthèque il y avait des
échantillons de soie imprimée qui ne
servaient à personne qui allait partir à
la poubelle
donc j'ai dit non moi je ne peux pas
laisser partir ça à la poubelle donc je
les ai récupérées et j'ai créé ma
première écharpe
de fil en aiguille elle fabrique
différentes écharpe soit circulaire soit
classique et même des foulards plusieurs
styles de soit utilisé des satins des
crêpes de chine détruits ou encore des
mousselines mon intérêt c'est de
mélanger les différentes soit pour avoir
des effets différents et pour ne pas
avoir un aspect trop lourd autour du cou
donc c'est pour ça que j'aime bien
mélanger les différentes matières
et c'est dans ce type de salon qu'elle
peut partager sa passion et donner de
précieux conseils
selon la manière dont vous allez place
et les chats retrouver
l'heure on se plaçait différemment voyez
là par exemple de la mecque comme ceux
ci l'a retourné dans l'autre sens et
faire à chaque fois une écharpe
différentes
je trouve ça très intéressant le choix
des matières et l'assemblage et les
assemblages houle avec qui
voilà les couleurs la matière et les
explications qui ont été données par la
suite mais voilà c'est l'originalité
voilà le fait d'avoir un article unique
que ce soit au salon ou dans son atelier
sandrine passe du temps à poser sa
griffe
elle vient de finir une écharpe
circulaire un temps de fabrication de
près d'une heure petit retour en arrière
sont découvrir ses secrets
je commence donc comme je disais à
brasser les soirs c'est à dire à les
mélanger à trouver quel imprimés va
correspondre à un autre quelle harmonie
de couleurs je vais créer
je vais maintenant les assemblées à la
machine pour démarrer mon panneau en
fait alors la couture anglais c'est une
couture double qui permet de
complètement emprisonner les bords du
tissu enfin les cacher les bords du
tissu pour éviter les effilochage et
rendre un résultat plus beaucoup plus
nets et mieux fini après chaque couture
jeu j'écrase d'abord ma couture d'abord
je coupe le bord du tissu
je repasse une première fois puis une
seconde fois et là maintenant je vais
refaire une deuxième piqûre autour de
cette première pour complètement fermée
six aux machines à coudre fer à repasser
sandrine répète ce mouvement jusqu à
finaliser son écharpe en période de
création elle passe entre huit et dix
heures par jour trois à quatre fois par
semaine dans son atelier à travailler
mais c'est avant tout une passion et un
plaisir de soi c'est un rendez-vous à
bien ancrée à saint quentin en yvelines
les 7e rencontres créactive se tiennent
demain et guyancourt
elles se dérouleront ce qui cube
l'incubateur de saint quentin en
yvelines à partir de midi demain c'est
organisé par l'association créée active
qui rassemble 160 chef d'entreprise est
porteuse de projets du territoire avec
moi au plateau de membres de ce réseau à
ma droite maimouna bas bonsoir donc vous
êtes membre de créative et vous êtes
également la directrice de la crèche la
bei et le papillon d'en dire un mot dans
un instant et à eve armand est avec moi
aussi un second soir vous êtes
fondatrice de la plate forme
collaborative partageons la formation
point com alors pour commencer
mesdames on va peut-être dire un mot sur
vos activités respectives et aussi
quelle importance pour vous de faire
partie de ce réseau kreactive on
commence par vous maimouna donc la
veille les papillons c'est une crèche
d'entreprise et à vocation inclusive
c'est ça il ya eu l'idée derrière de
d'égalité dès le berceau c'est quelque
chose qui est qu'ils en sortent de cette
crèche exactement alors nous développons
un nouveau modèle de crèches
d'entreprise
l'idée c'est de créer de la mixité au
sein des établissements parce qu'on
pense que et
les crèches doivent être plus que des
crèches aujourd'hui et effectivement
nous accueillons des salariés des
entreprises du territoire et nous
accueillons également donc des personnes
qui sont dans des parcours d'insertion
et l'idée c'est de concourir à l'égalité
des chances et à l'égalité entre les
genres dès le berceau et sur l'adhésion
à créactive pourquoi qu'est ce que
qu'est-ce que ça vous apporte de faire
partie de ce réseau d'entrepreneurs
alors je pense qu'on en tout cas moi je
suis rentré dans che créactive pour
sortir un petit peu de l'isolément de
l'entrepreneur puisque c'est pas évident
d'être chef d'entreprise et encore moins
d'être femme chef d'entreprise et ce
réseau en fait moi m'a apporté du réseau
déjà il m'a apporté également des
échanges instructifs et solidaire
également bienveillant avec d'autres
chefs d'entreprise qui est partagé les
mêmes difficultés les mêmes
problématiques que moi en tant que femme
eve armand vous de votre côté partageons
la formation points comme c'est quoi en
quelques mois partageant la formation
points comme c'est le premier organisme
de formation version collaborative
l'objectif est de permettre aux
entreprises de se regrouper pour
partager les coûts de la formation est
en phase de permettre aux formateurs aux
experts métiers formateur de se
regrouper pour partager les mêmes
valeurs et dans une même démarche
qualité alors vous me disiez tout à
l'heure juste avant ce journal que ccvo
cinquième rencontre demain ça sera votre
cinquième rencontre créative
effectivement j'ai démarré mon activité
il ya 5 ans à l'époque j'étais porteur
de projet je réfléchis c'est justement
cette activité à l'étude de marché et
pour parler ton activité
rien de mieux que de rencontrer en fait
d'autres entrepreneurs et créactive
s'est imposé comme mon réseau de coeur
donc ça sera la septième édition demain
de ces rencontres ouvert à toutes et à
tous porteurs de projets dirigeant
aguerri aussi qu'ils vont pouvoir se se
rencontrer réseauter c'est quelque chose
de primordial quand on est dans le monde
de l'entreprise
maimouna oui complètement enfin je pense
que c'est plus que nécessaire et alors
c'est nécessaire à plusieurs égards
c'est nécessaire un pour le business
mais c'est nécessaire aussi
donc un don pour pourrez échanger et
sortir de la solitude de l'entrepreneur
alors pour ces rencontres demain le
thème c'est osons parler d'argent c'est
une thématique tabou dans l'entreprise
de parler d'argent tabou je n'irai pas
jusque là mais ça peut être parfois
difficile comment défendre ses prix
comment les présenter comment parler
aussi de tous ces thèmes de la cession
d'entreprise voilà il ya différentes
activités et sujet sur les gens qui sont
abordés de nous d'ailleurs demande en
qualité d'experte et et de en
développement pardon commercial est en
formation professionnelle vous animerez
une table ronde sur sur cette thématique
ozon défendre nos prix et donc il sera
question de ce que vous venez de dire
c'est à présenter ses prix comment les
construire déjà série comment les
présenter il y aura d'autres thèmes
d'autres tables rondes il ya aussi des
stands
pour rencontrer des professionnels du
sang vous faites très bien la transition
des stands et vous maimouna vous serez
sur un stand vous animerez instant
demain pour pour ces rencontres
exactement je serai sur le stand de
l'abeille et le papillon donc je
présenterai l'activité la bei et le
papillon donc aux personnes qui seront
là et met enfin à côté également
d'autres partenaires comme la société
générale bnp courtois automobile et le
réseau libre réseau c'est ça la journée
de demain s'articulera finalement au
tour de table ronde 2 e stand également
oui vous vouliez ajouter quelque chose
tout le détail sur les nombreux stands
et les tables rondes sont disponibles
sur les sites www point créé active avec
anais ce point org - qui s'affiche
d'ailleurs actuellement pour nous
téléspectateurs on va terminer il faut
s'inscrire oui on le sait reste un
événement gratuit mais sur inscription
préalable puisque le nombre de places et
est bien sûr limité pour clôturer cet
entretien juste un petit tour de table
vos attentes respectives autour de
l'événement qu'elle quelles sont elles
m.ben toujours du partage bienveillant
du partage amical du partage
d'expériences et apprendre toujours de
nouvelles choses
maimouna votre côté je pense qu'elle a
tout dit hantée qu'elle a bien résumé
les choses est effectivement de l'
échange du réseautage et puis bah pour
moi c'est aussi parler de cette crèche
un petit peu atypique sur le territoire
aux entreprises du territoire
merci à vous deux en tout cas d'avoir
été avec vous êtes toutes les deux je
rappelle membres de créative et donc f
vous gérez la patte de la plateforme
vous est la fondatrice de la plateforme
partageons la formation points comme
maimouna directrice maimouna bas de la
crèche la bei et le papillon et je
précise un jour précise que cette
rencontre kreactive de demain et sur
inscription gratuite et vous le faites
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran
le sport une nouvelle victoire pourra
les handballeurs de plaisir ils se sont
imposés ce dimanche face à marolles un
adversaire direct au classement les
plaisirs waha s'installe à la seconde
place à deux longueurs du leader
retour sur la rencontre avec nicolas
landry ils ont répondu présent pour
cette rencontre importante les plaisirs
oies se sont imposé 29 à 27 face à
marolles une équipe redoutable qui
pointait au troisième rang du classement
avant ce match à égalité de points avec
plaisir une quatrième victoire de suite
pour l'équipe de victor garrigues et 22e
places et une deuxième place en jeu donc
voilà on est à égalité de points avec
marolles 6e gagner ce deuxième et nous
cinquième c'est proclamant donc voir et
puis on avait surtout à coeur de faire
une bonne prestation à domicile quoi
avec cela sa lettre est très costaud
c'est très bien préparé toute la semaine
et on est content ça paye trois points
pour une victoire pas évidente
un début de partie équilibré entre les
deux équipes marolles a mené pendant une
partie de la première mi temps puis la
rencontre bascule lorsque les plaisirs
oies se retrouvent en supériorité
numérique on a fait 15 très très bonne
minutes en fin de première mi temps on
arrive à passer devant et je pense qu'à
partir de ce moment-là psychologiquement
on les a atteint et on est revenu avec
les mêmes intentions de mes deuxièmes et
je pense qu'on a très bien exploité un
moment donné où ils ont décidé de jouer
un joueur de plus où
on a on a pris le choix tactiques de ne
pas s'attirer des secteurs dans la
circulation
un choix tactique qui a permis à plaisir
de récupérer des ballons et de marquer
dans une cage vide plusieurs fois coupé
à une défense agressive sur les dix
mètres la recette plaisir oise pour
l'emporter sur plusieurs défensives
qu'on travaille depuis maintenant
sa quatrième saison et on a on en tire
bien les ficelles et on sait agir là où
on doit agir
on sait agir là où les rapports de force
en notre faveur je pense que maintenant
on va être attendu un peu partout et que
rien n'est joué cette saison on perd
deux matches on est huitième on en gagne
deux on est premiers donc voilà chaque
mois je vais très très important et
décisif en toute humilité les hommes de
victor garrigues et vont poursuivre le
travail à l'entraînement et prendre les
matches les uns après les autres avec
comme objectif de tous les remporter
avant de refermer ce journal l'histoire
avait rendez vous avec versailles ce
week-end la 10e édition du salon
histoire de lire étaient au programme
plus d'une centaine d'auteurs décès de
romans et de bd est présent pour des
dédicaces et des rencontres
mélanie poquet et nicolas landry le
général de gaulle en héros de bande
dessinée
jean-yves le naour a choisi de partager
l'histoire grâce au neuvième art
quand j'écris des ouvrages d'histoire je
vois très bien mon lectorat il est
généralement il a les tempes argentées
il a les cheveux blancs le lectorat
kylie des ouvrages sur la première
guerre mondiale bien souvent il a plus
de 50 ans quand j'écris en revanche des
bandes dessinées j'ai un lectorat
beaucoup plus jeunes d'adolescents
à partir de 8 ans de 9 ans de 10 ans
comme jean-yves le naour plus de 100
auteurs étaient rassemblés à l'hôtel de
ville de versailles et du département
deux jours de rencontres et de dédicaces
pour les amoureux d'histoire
j'achète beaucoup de livres j'en lis dès
que je peux je sais pas toujours c'est
pas toujours facile mais indique jeu dès
que je peux et je trouve cette
manifestation et
et est une manifestation importante et
très très intéressant très agréable et
d'ailleurs une partie de cette
manifestation se passe aussi l'hôtel la
préfecture je suis très impressionné
parce que je pensais que c'était un
petit salon
avec peu de peu d'auteurs et je vois que
c'est immense
je suis très très impressionné et très
impressionné par la qualité de l'accueil
si l'organisation pour une rencontre
avec des écrivains qui sont tous de très
grande qualité et d'avoir un accès
direct avec un choix assez
extraordinaire en fait d'où leur âge qui
sont tous ceux qui ont la peau
stationnera lors ce qui est très
difficile c'est de faire son choix
pour sa dixième édition le salon
histoire de lire a accueilli plus de
20000 visiteurs et nous vous proposerons
à cette semaine dans nos éditions un
entretien avec une des personnalités qui
était présente sur ce salon histoire de
lire c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
ripley et reportages à retrouver sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv 60,18 bonne soirée et
excellente semaine à tous
[Musique]